I'm really good we got both here but in
general right I've seen it I've seen new
comments I've I've studied your comments
people tend to think that or regard you
as a high value woman and people have
said that right
um I don't know if you agree with
disagree but people have said that I
think a high value woman's a virgin I'm
not a virgin fair enough fair enough
lease yourself away yeah but I think I
think they just gas me up
but so you say you're not a high volume
but would you would you be okay with
that genuinely okay someone special
Odyssey Odyssey would you be okay with
it would you be okay for one special
you're not think of did I say stutter
did I did I stutter somehow I think I
would self-respected that but fair
enough my point is is that the sort of
women that would say yes it's called
we're on a discount I don't know no I
wouldn't I wouldn't like that but I
don't think if I if if I had kids I
wouldn't leave that's that's a bit
different though I think that's a bit
different if I'm young
depends how young like if I'm 30 and I
don't got kids yeah I might have to stay
like where's the grass greener I'm 30
now like
but I get what you're saying with you
know the whole 30 thing but generally
right now your age you wouldn't you
wouldn't be okay I wouldn't prefer it
now and so I think that shows that
already the pool of women that would
actually be okay with with that sort of
Lifestyle right it's not exactly the
best pool I
honestly it
yeah a lot of girls would be okay with
it but then just because it's a lot
doesn't mean they're good quantity isn't
always quality no you could argue that
but
I don't know I I think there's more
girls that'd be okay with it that you
don't have to listen to like what girls
say watch what they do no no I don't
doubt that but what I'm saying is
generally yeah the whip surely be
looking for if you're going to have a
woman in your life and take it seriously
you surely be looking for like the
exceptional ones rather than the the
ones that would be okay
two for one not even a discount
surely you'd want the best of the best
or the best that you can get rather than
yeah you know the ones that okay being
one of 20 yeah because there is nothing
I wanted to
I mean personally I'm good I'd rather
have one wife right okay well we'll try
this out to someone else
I'm sure there'll be some takers
[Laughter]
Kevin said 30 off at 27.
I'm 25 but I'm like going off early you
know
it's like an early sale oh he's 26 this
year yeah I'm 26 in November it's coming
close man it's coming now
[Music]
um no I mean I don't know I'm not a guy
so I I'd imagine that I don't know
politician wives like they seem pretty
high quality women a lot of them so like
Melania Trump I'm sorry I think she's a
high quality woman she gets cheated on
like like but is that is that lifestyle
can you prescribe that lifestyle to the
average person because fair enough and
again that's another problem I have with
this sort of content you're saying this
to the people who will never reach that
level yeah but then they're still going
to try to implement it into their lives
and it won't go well for them and then
they'll Wonder they'll be it's just
further propagate The Narrative that
these women are trash more than women
have bad money but then you can't
sustain that lifestyle you don't have
the finances or you're not the sort of
person that can sustain that sort of
Lifestyle well I think they push men to
get that sort of Lifestyle so they can
do that that partially that's the whole
but why why I don't understand why
that's the thing you should be pushing
them towards I think you should be
pushing them to become better they want
money too and muscles yeah but that's
what I'm saying I think you should push
them to become better and generally I've
seen in life that as you get more
muscles people tend to like you more as
you get more money people tend to like
you more however rather than just making
that the goal right the women be the
goal why not just try to make men just
better in general
um I would say that's what they do they
push men to be better overall not not
Rollo it depends on the content creator
yeah but yeah I would say most of them
push men to be better overall and get
women in the process
but do you think that Emmanuel they
always say never chase women they say
that but then they contradict themselves
so if you if you say if you're telling
guys right that you shouldn't marry you
you shouldn't marry or settle down a
woman until you've had at least 40
bodies right don't you think that
someone tells you that there's only one
channel
but that's one of the biggest ones and
if you're telling if you're telling guys
that that's the thing you should be
doing surely that you're gonna be
chasing
it's a lot of bodies
yeah well
I mean they can they can do that of
course they can but this is what I'm
saying if someone contradicts the
message right there well I think I think
it's more like to get practice with
games you only need 40 buddies for
practicing
some people some you know some Shooters
do the extra mile after breakfast
they'll really put me you'll be putting
in jump shots you know
so like some people just want to go the
extra you know that's that's bad that's
bad I mean it could be ten it could be
20. that's right I will say I think most
girls can feel it if a guy's an
experienced with women and not in like a
good way it's sad it's sad because like
before birth control happened like they
wouldn't have to yeah but like the
world's different now and it's sad but
it's just like is what it is
The World Isn't like it used to be
but surely you know if you have a
platform where you can influence
people's decisions not you specifically
what I'm saying in general if you have a
platform where
because I've seen people ask them this
um ask a lot of these weather people
this sort of question where you know you
have a platform where you can influence
people why wouldn't you use it to try to
do it right in terms of making it go
towards the other way so they tend to
always mention the fact that oh well
this is our biological imperatives yeah
this is what we want to do and so it
doesn't look we're trying to yeah to
fight it but surely I say build your own
platform and do it yourself that's what
I'm trying to do that's what I'm trying
to do criticize what other people do
with their platforms some people just
want to be informational but as
informational and then there's you're
still prescribing stuff like you can be
information I mean I just okay unless
you give me specific people I don't know
who you're talking about because like
you'll kind of ask me like about the red
pill in general but there's a lot of
variations between the the channels okay
so right now like if we're talking about
fresh and fit right they give advice
they're an advice Channel and they feel
like the best way to get leverage over
women is to screw as many as possible
and there's some there's some evidence
that supports it because like you know
girls
girls Bond through like orgasms so if
you get better at sex like you can get
more girls obsessed with you like that's
not fun but it's just how girls Bond
yeah and you can even see like Reddit
threads and like Tick Tock threads
um like where girls talk about how they
miss the best sex of their life and that
sort of thing so
that's yeah that's fair but that's I I
wouldn't I wouldn't recommend that but I
can understand why they would you know
yeah no that's good that's fair I've
only got a couple minutes left so I just
want to ask you one last question one
question
would you rather
start an early funds okay where you do
whatever people request oh god oh
be one of agitates women
everyone Andrew dates women before I
freaking did it only fans no I mean at
least he's like he's rich like if I'm
gonna cry I'm gonna cry my Mansion like
get the
I would much rather do that than put my
body on the internet for everyone else
to see I mean you'd be one of those come
girls though
everyone I don't think so I swear as
usually kind of goes not anymore that
was back like when he started he does
casinos now oh yeah that's true yeah I'm
pretty sure it's kind of business though
he might I don't think his main chick is
on cams I don't know he has a girlfriend
he's a uh his girlfriend like six years
he's got wow yeah yeah like I heard I
heard someone say that before they would
they wouldn't be serious like no yeah I
would pick as long as if I'm on the cam